[Music]
this morning on the dish joe and shayna
pappaj their restaurant the harvey house
sits less than a mile from the wisconsin
state capitol and is aiming to be at the
center of dining in madison and beyond
it's the result of a long journey for
two culinary professionals who fell in
love with food before falling in love
with each other
so you're gonna go first to 31 with
these two salmon one and two chef joe
papich spent his career working in some
of the country's most prestigious
kitchens but he's built a home at the
harvey house put all this stuff back
every single time in the same spot the
restaurant he and his wife shayna opened
in madison wisconsin
where the couple pairs their culinary
chops with their midwestern roots this
is midwest hospitality at its finest
you could not have
this place without kielbasa somehow on
the menu i mean some sort of cheesy
sausage is out there and it had to come
in here for sure for this seasonal soup
papiche squeezes cheese fondue over peas
then dusts it with mint powder then the
server will come and then they just do
this last minute of pouring of the soup
into the cream
this is so good
that mint it's like just the hint of
mint
joe and shaina are something of a
culinary power couple each graduates of
east coast culinary schools who've
worked alongside dining royalty but
there's only one cook in this kitchen
do you miss being back there ever
i do not
i love the design
i love sort of the general hospitality i
love creating relationships with guests
i like cooking so
and you are really good at it thanks
the harvey house is inspired by midwest
supper clubs which date back to the
prohibition era its updated menu
features an instagram worthy relish tray
seasonal vegetables and an aerated
whipped ranch with dill served with a
smoked trout dip and toast
cannelloni with a chart eggplant
bechamel
topped with a lacquer of cheese fondue
fruit and vegetables rib eye steak with
a palm puree a past on legendary potato
puree from french laundry so it's
there's only one way to make pom puree
and that's the way we do it and we'll
never we'll never make it another way
again i'm destroying the work of art oh
you're supposed to
and lake superior walleye an ode to a
fish fry and then we get lots of
questions about how we get that skin so
crispy so it's just a very thinly sliced
piece of rye bread yep so it's like
you're emulating skin but you're adding
just another flavor to the crunch it's
better than the skin no buttery toast
yeah buttery toast joe and shayna's
partnership goes back 16 years starting
as strictly business at new york's
gramercy tavern he was my boss
and it was my first job out of culinary
school when did boss go to
i'd like this to not just be boss
for a long time actually not for a long
time can i get cheddar moose over joe
left new york for the west coast
eventually becoming sous chef for thomas
keller at the french laundry shayno went
to grad school and did stints for the
likes of dan barber and alice waters
including at her edible schoolyard
project
i was already at french laundry my
friend was asking me how he can elevate
school lunch in the bay area
and i was single at the time and i was
like i know a woman that knows so much
about this ulterior motives i'm going to
talk to i'm going to talk to her about
that
yeah before we knew it i think we're
married and
they nearly opened a restaurant in napa
valley before abruptly moving back to
shaina's hometown the night before we
were supposed to sign the lease on a
restaurant space in saint helena where
we were living at the time
we were walking around and we were like
i don't think this is the right move i
was pregnant with max our first son we
were very very close with my family and
joe's family lives in indiana and felt
like it would be
a good spot to like go to to find just
the right space for a restaurant the
couple found inspiration far from
wisconsin
we spent a little bit of time in europe
after joe finished the french laundry
after having been in france and seeing
all of these incredible you know
old historic buildings yeah just like
very romantic but
you know you're like okay we're going to
go back to the u.s and go back there
nothing's really that old you know so
until they discovered madison's historic
train depot built in 1903 all but
abandoned since it went out of service
more than 50 years ago we came in here
and it was like we want to do this this
is where it's going to be joe and shaina
spent three years excavating and
renovating the old train stop into a 5
000 square foot dining destination this
was the train platform um where people
caught the trains and we put the trotso
floor in and i guess what would a train
station be without the train exactly the
train car this is where we're headed so
we do private dining on here okay it's a
great place for holiday parties or
birthday parties something a little more
intimate this track that's laid down
here is not operational okay there is an
operational truck on the other side so
trains do come by
so when you're sitting in here a couple
times a night you do get a train which
is fun oh that's crazy
they named the restaurant mostly as an
homage to fred harvey who opened a chain
of eateries along train routes in the
late 1800s
and inspired the 1946 film the harvey
girls starring judy garland
and they were called the harvey houses
but my paternal grandfather is also
named harvey and so we felt like it was
a very nice connection the harvey house
is where the packages have settled down
sort of
running the restaurant and raising their
family joe's 14 year old and their three
kids together son charlie already
showing promise in the family business
hello everybody i'm chef charlie
plus me we need handball gummy and self
cuz he loves charlie did he just do it
on his own or it was during the pandemic
and we were born he went he was bored
i was also voting was bored people still
come up to him today i was like chef
charlie how was your tune
balancing it all is hard work but with
help from their staff and family these
two make it look like a piece of cake
this is like little piece of nostalgia
it sure is there's no tin foil for me to
unwrap yeah there's no battling a
package in this case a classic chocolate
swiss roll and a strawberries and cream
pavlova everything good in all of this
oh yeah totally thank you for joining us
and of course
we brought you this because i looked at
this and i told joe like as long as you
have this
everybody's good this is a like a
step back in time and taste and the
whole place i got to tell you we have an
old fashioned here the drink menu is
incredibly crafted also along with all
the foods that are seasonal you know i
had a harvey hopper which was like a
grasshopper there was a pink squirrel
drink it name it it just was a step back
in time and if you know supper clubs it
really does have that feel and if you
don't you should go because you'll
understand it it's an entire feeling
there's such a sense of nostalgia there
in tradition but this modern twist on it
beautiful i have nothing to say i know
isn't that so good